hello I'm telling lives boxing trainer
of champions and I'm harvelle Jenkins
cut man to some of your favorite
fighters has the condition of our
reduced sentence we've been caught
ordered to inform you of a often
forgotten hazard we've been forced to
tell you the dangers of ingesting too
much carbon monoxide aka the Dutch
headlock remember you sit in your car
listening to your favorite songs with
the garage door closed set a time limit
like no more than Ronnie Milsaps
Greatest Hits okay so if your friends
are Dan you to hide in the trunk of a
car while the engines running and the
garage door is closed you tell them yes
again you ain't no Punk instead of your
arguments with an ice pick or hit them
from behind with a shovel like a man and
if you want to see how long you can hold
your breath without dying do it
underwater
like at home and you're taller carbon
monoxide is like AIDS you ain't going
with you bet off planning your car with
sex offenders and fireworks don't be an
idiot
leave carbon monoxide poisoning to the
experts see Ghana's más que estas vas
America nyah